there's lots of [ __ ] in this office oh
my job whoa that one's purple also lots
of props why is that one purple one wait
wait where'd you go right here we're
right here is very okay and my purple
yes cool Harry
who your purple circle draw everyone
lose it why can't I see oh there we go
oh I'm not gonna bring it oh [ __ ] what
the hell I don't know it's weird your
texture pack does not exist apparently
the state I'm your little buddy let's go
hunt Wade cookies let's go bring him
down he said I win delete him out he
might be over here on your side
where'd he go where'd that douche go the
distinctive do smell if I can't find him
kill me that's how loyal I am alright I
can't find him you might as well just
kill me there I guess then I'll hold him
out as a ghost worthy oh there he is
he's a book
he's a book he's running up the eastern
stairs he might be coming behind you who
he's the bodies now oh he's a runnin you
and your aim was way off I don't know
how you hit him shotgun what did you do
haha hit in the darkness in front of bum
bum
oh really did you know do I have a plan
I do have a plan pop you've the worst
poker face oh I see something I saw
somethin movin wait keep an eye on one
Bob Wade key right now so flex my eyes
go in the other side where is he no no
no no no it's Bob
but I was trying to get I ran out the
door
and Mark was running right past me and I
just stopped and I was like Oh
Eddie red best me because I was in the
shadow and then you announced it to the
world that didn't go well clever girl
Jack clever girl in sight
clever grill clever grill Bear Grylls
okay Jack Jack you should not have done
that what had he done
he may have announced his presence to
wait a little bit
Oh rotations gonna be able to figure out
what's going on here all right I thought
that would have given it away but oh
well no to project boy gonna watch it
outside the window the whole wait a
minute okay no well hmm all right
this is funny but it's not fair Jackie's
now that that desk at all okay I think
it's safe to come out then Jack are you
doing huh you an actual yeah
in the hallway the other part of the
wrong trashcan I'm shooting the entire
time this blood everywhere it's just
notice how legitimate I was that pretty
helpful
Oh
rolls don't forget damn it Oh Oh can we
not be that now oh that's that's bad for
me it's bad for me oh [ __ ] what are you
doing well I'm trying to Charlie oh that
prop has been banned by the server okay
that makes sense
well I'll just you know
what area you know you don't need to
concern yourself with that wait okay I
want to know what band prompt mark was
trying to be yeah let's try to be cute
urmass it didn't work it's too small
it's too small don't mind me myself not
bothering nobody
well you two walked past me first like
the whole office was chaos just destroy
every word you guys didn't even look I
got this mark don't worry let me see
where they don't know the area wait that
actually word would work yeah can it
work all right keep a lookout so I can
see if I can check boxes wait what is
fragile a mean it means handle with care
oh it does guarantee of quality
oh he's frag I'll know he's 4G lay its
fringe yeah four inch it's for a leg
lamp
no use Big Bob or up he's on the move
I'll come and Jack don't you worry yeah
see ya saved you hit him you think you
hit him you didn't hit him he's in the
office again he's a [ __ ] core person
he's a runnin he's a runnin he's a
runner
see this is why this is my way to deal
properly kill himself when you do it you
just sound so douchey when you're doing
it
skill that's winning me this manly in
reality way I know I just lost the last
five you're down there hey that's how
you know it's a good session mm-hmm
every time I finish a recording session
if I'm honest it's not covered in my own
saliva then it's not going to go God oh
no what happened I immediately regret
all of these decisions what I only
believe you won a 4-time hmm jeez Bob
mercy what the hell he's right he's
right there it's not fair it's so hard
to hit him yes I got killed Oh God there
you are
wait can we go outside we just being
quiet you disappeared so I decided to
bag Mark's dead body you weren't it
didn't even look like you were
teabagging me wait why are we leaving
life yeah are you Bob Bobby you plant no
I'm not a plant I'm not a plant he was a
cool im'a or a can I contain things
though
cool could you could put things it
wasn't cool that means he's a box no he
wasn't Cup now he's a dick all right if
you just slow down a little bit wait I'm
sure actually I can't I can't even see
where you are Bob really yeah you would
wait are you some of those cases where I
think Bob's using misdirection to lie to
me no I'm right next to you wait I'm in
this room right next to me I proud I'm
not right next to you know I'm not
directly and I see but I'm in this room
with you I promise
yeah he didn't leave the video the video
evidence will show I am in this room and
at some point are you
and filing cabinet in a room of nothing
but filing cabinets Oh
maybe um question I'm not gonna say oh I
see him
okay that makes Sophie a lot okay you
see me I see you you're intersecting
your dollar
that won't tell you know I tell what you
are don't reveal it but he's
intersecting slightly right yeah yeah
okay I think I got him he's not a right
angle
he's a wrong yeah but Wade you're never
gonna find him what went wrong I'm not
wrong okay wait wrong wrong try to get
Bob if you walk into if you walk into
the fight but if you're it don't walk
around and push there's always a chance
it weed might give up wait right there
Oh Bob this is always
i what this okay I turned away and it
looked more inconspicuous because
something fell over there is this is I
hate this is the worst Oh God
wait do you see what they did what did
he do I can't move right now mark I did
something bad yep it's not like it's not
horrific ly obvious but evidence points
to my stupidity I don't know there's a
bunch of order over here don't worry
about it I can't figure out
I could I could try and pressure that
weights over there these doors god damn
it yeah he knocked this plane oh I know
yeah that's what I wanted to do but why
would that get me stuck like it
literally it's a stupid waiter you're
boned
wait you're behind we'd wait apparently
you're not boom wait I might have given
it away
sounded like you said n-word risk in it
why no that's it sound like oh I forgot
okay this is this is where I'm stuck
forever now where's that definitely
right there
yeah right there let's get in it that's
getting it oh okay how is so [ __ ] as
soon as you came around that corner oh
whoa whoa well I don't know about really
good cuz you seem to get into spots like
[ __ ] alright especially wait coz Bob
seems to be able to smell me oh I have a
very inquisitive mind out here okay I
think I'm in a good spot I think I'm in
a good
wait are you good oh okay we're good
welcome today I'm here I'm here on my
friend Boehner Bob Boehner's can we call
in to the Boehner cast you're on with
the Boehner cast okay I have a problem
with my Boehner is it supposed to turn
green and yellow absolutely hello you've
reached the Boehner cast your Boehner
Jack what's your Boehner question oh hey
I have my little old lady don't mind my
voice it's very weird I always wondered
what what does a good Boehner look like
cuz I I feel like in my life I've only
seen bad moaners see ma'am when you come
stub owners they're like a fine wine
some of them are better some of them are
worse some others better with age the
age better with age some are soft summer
hard covers different shapes different
nationalities I just realized I'm
looking for people thank you do you
think I could get a look at your own
I storm was dying I'm currently at 10
frames per second so life it's not going
so well for me you got drop resolution
wait call into the boner test hello
you've reached the boner cast Oh mark
yeah mark you answer this one mark you
can have it no you're dead I'll get my
first boner just come over here and sit
in my lap he's a cop he's up next to
another cup it's pretty uh he's on a
coffee table right by the door behind
you it's like the Bob and Tom show it's
always just other people they know
calling in the same same well except for
my character she died mid call so she
never got a say she was older for the
first time we have we have a grace yeah
you got time what's up you got them oh
come on frame rate what are you doing to
me what if you like stop everything and
start again yeah that probably would fix
it yeah we'll wait here don't worry it
sounds like a buffering issue
sounds like a boner
yes are like Macho Man Randy Savage when
you're honored
well you need the three people three
people on every podcast you need a three
three man crew you have the one with the
voice you have the the laughy guy that's
Bob and then Jack you can have the third
person you're the caller we have to call
out to you on location you're always at
the beach like checking I was in the
trouble bear used to be on the all right
and I'm in and I'm in an awesome
position I'm prepared okay you guys
ready okay I don't know what Jack's
doing but I'm prepared well I'm going to
be 30 so because we might as well wait
we're going to wait yeah yeah you run
with boner Cass what's your boner
such a huge fan yo one time I got like
wasted with my friends and we all
touched each other's boners hands but
it's just what is that gay nothing wrong
with a little boner tetr-a gays where
I'm from it's the Broner love that's
what it is
owner the boners called Boney's
uncertain cuz I don't want to make
anything boner cannon for your boner
podcast so just let me not intrude
you're developing the boner keep the
boners ship since what you fire off
every time you get a sweet choice
people with boner casts could get signed
by the boner cast oh I broke my boner
watching your weight wait wait just just
stand right here great spot guys
hello you're on the boat okay Eugene I
have a particularly large boner it's
almost too big do you think I should get
boner reduction surgery okay are you
saying like gurren lagaan my boner is
the boner that will pierce the heavens
when people are ready to accept your
greatness
they will carve Mount bone more into the
side of your boners like this it will be
exact because it's hard to carve giant
mountain scars carving sculptures but
you know it'll be close enough and
everyone will remember the gloriousness
thank you I appreciate it I feel so much
better about my Jain boner good call oh
my god the phone's right off though look
Oh God Oh Nicole hello you're a butt
okay ass
hi I'm like a college student and gonna
be a teacher and stuff and I really suck
at using laser pointers is it okay to
just use my boner lying some pilots with
that [ __ ] what do you say about the tip
man [ __ ] do you see use just the tip
yeah brother
okay nope I guess just the end of the
boat